This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了在这个奇怪的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身和建立复原力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有比这更重要的黑人年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
请在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要表现出来。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
请在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德被指控让人生下双胞胎。但怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭开一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。格雷，一个女同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。请在IHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。
I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。请收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。大家好。
I'm Gemma Spike and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. You guys know the deal. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. There is a very famous saying, at least I think it's famous, that if it was easy, everybody would be doing it. And when I was in university, I used to have that printed out on like a piece of paper.
我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《二十岁的心理学》，这是一个我们讨论二十岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听众，老听众，无论你在世界的哪个角落。你们都知道规矩。很高兴你们能回来收听新的一集，当然，我们要剖析二十岁的心理。有一句非常著名的话，至少我认为它很出名，那就是如果事情很容易，每个人都会去做。当我在大学时，我曾经把它打印在一张纸上。
I think I even wrote it out. And I had it blue-tacked on my wall above my desk. And when I was studying for exams, when I was working through assignments, it was kind of like my go-to phrase for motivation to like embrace the hard stuff, to appreciate that hard things bring about the best rewards, that kind of gist. However, as I have gotten older and I was thinking about that quote the other day, and this is what has inspired that episode, as I've got to, and older. I've sort of revised my thinking around this. You know, yes, definitely. Some of the best things
我想我甚至把它写了下来。我把它用蓝丁胶贴在书桌上方的墙上。当我为考试学习时，当我处理作业时，它就像我寻求动力的首选短语，去拥抱困难的事情，去欣赏困难的事情能带来最好的回报，大概就是这个意思。然而，随着我年龄的增长，前几天我在思考那句名言，这也是激发这一集灵感的原因，随着我年龄的增长。我已经修正了对这一点的看法。你知道，是的，绝对是。生活中一些最好的事情
in life do demand a lot of our effort, time, energy, attention. But does that necessarily mean that they need to be unenjoyable or difficult? Does it always have to be such like a mental slug? I think those words and like concepts tend to get all melted together when we talk about doing hard things. We imagine that they have to be almost painful. I also think, you know, with that quote, there is also this underlying secondary sense that maybe you and I, we don't deserve success if we don't almost suffer for it, if we don't strive for it, if it, you know, came to us easily. Today, I want to talk about that. I want to talk about this idea of how we can train our brain to do hard things by offering you a different approach, a different formula or understanding,
确实需要我们付出大量的努力、时间、精力、注意力。但这是否一定意味着它们必须是不愉快的或困难的呢？难道总是必须像一种精神上的苦差事吗？我认为当我们谈论做困难的事情时，这些词汇和概念往往会混在一起。我们想象它们必须几乎是痛苦的。我还认为，你知道，那句名言背后还有一种潜在的次要含义，即如果我们不为之付出痛苦，如果我们不为之奋斗，如果它（你知道）轻易地来到我们身边，我们就不配获得成功。今天，我想谈谈这一点。我想谈谈这个想法，即我们可以通过为你提供一种不同的方法、一种不同的公式或理解来训练我们的大脑去做困难的事情，
one in which hard things become easier using some of these principles of psychology that mean that we find difficult tasks less mentally taxing. We find it less difficult to start. We appreciate the rewards more. You know, all motivation, our desire to do anything big, or small, even the most mundane of tasks. It all starts in the brain and it all starts with how we perceive how difficult the thing in front of us is and how we perceive the outcome and the rewards of our hard effort. That is actually something that we can influence, we can influence how our
在这种理解中，利用一些心理学原则，使困难的事情变得更容易，这意味着我们发现困难的任务在精神上不那么繁重。我们发现开始做起来不那么困难。我们更欣赏回报。你知道，所有的动力，我们做任何事情的欲望，无论大小，即使是最平凡的任务。这一切都始于大脑，始于我们如何感知面前的事情有多困难，以及我们如何感知我们努力工作的成果和回报。这实际上是我们能够影响的事情，我们可以影响我们的
brain kind of perceives all of these components and mean that the hard, difficult things that all of us have to do in our 20s, like the things that are just so frustrating and annoying and that we often put off become less of a chore. I will also say our brain does like a challenge, even when it's a bit physically, mentally painful. That's something that I think sometimes we forget when we just keep taking the easy route, which I'm definitely guilty of.
大脑如何感知所有这些组成部分，这意味着我们二十岁时必须做的那些困难、艰巨的事情，比如那些让人感到沮丧和烦恼、我们经常推迟的事情，会变得不那么像苦差事。我还要说，我们的大脑确实喜欢挑战，即使它在身体上、精神上有点痛苦。当我们总是选择走容易的路时，我们有时会忘记这一点，我肯定也犯过这种错。
The New York Marathon, as I'm recording this, was I think a couple of weeks ago. I love the New York Marathon, and every time I watch it, I think, why does anyone want to do that? And the answer is that the feeling of doing hard things that exert us is something that we actually value as humans. That is something that actually we do need more of in our lives. It all comes down to this thing known as the effort paradox. The more effort we put into something, the more we value it.
在我录制这一集时，纽约马拉松赛我想是几周前举行的。我喜欢纽约马拉松，每次看的时候，我都会想，为什么有人想做那个？答案是，做那些让我们费力的事情的感觉，是我们人类真正重视的东西。这确实是我们生活中更需要的东西。这一切都归结为所谓的“努力悖论”。我们投入的努力越多，我们就越重视它。
That's why, you know, you value the crappy mug that you made at a pottery class over the perfect mug that you got at IKEA. The end of a hard project is valued more than the outcome of an easy one, and it actually does make our life feel more fulfilling. We feel proud of ourselves, and we just reap the rewards. So today, let us break down exactly how we can use the principles of behavioral psychology, mainly, but also neuroscience to do the hard things, to start the hard routines, especially in our 20s when we can reap a lot of lifelong rewards from getting into the habit from biting the bullet. So without further ado, let's break down the psychology of how you and I can train our brains to do just that. The journey to completing or starting anything
这就是为什么，你知道，你比在宜家买的完美马克杯更珍惜你在陶艺课上做的那个糟糕的马克杯。一个困难项目的结束比一个简单项目的成果更受重视，它确实让我们的生活感觉更充实。我们为自己感到自豪，我们只是收获了回报。所以今天，让我们剖析一下我们如何利用行为心理学，主要是行为心理学，但也包括神经科学来做困难的事情，开始困难的日常工作，特别是在我们二十岁的时候，当我们从养成习惯、咬牙坚持中获得很多终身回报时。所以事不宜迟，让我们剖析一下你和我如何训练我们的大脑做到这一点。完成或开始任何事情的旅程
hard all actually has the exact same start line. And the start line is going from doing nothing to doing something. And I think a lot of us know that that transition, that jump from doing nothing to something is the hardest. And it stops a lot of us from ever really beginning, even if we really, really want to see where something's going to take us. That is why my first biggest tip for how we can train our brain to do hard things is the five-minute rule. You know, after you begin, the first five minutes of anything is going to be the hardest because you have to be the hardest. have to dig deep and find the motivation to just begin and to deal with that tension from going from doing nothing to doing something. And a big part of why that is so daunting is that it feels like
困难的事情实际上都有完全相同的起点。起点就是从什么都不做变成做点什么。我想我们很多人都知道，那种转变，从无到有的跳跃是最困难的。它阻止了我们很多人真正开始，即使我们真的、真的想看看某件事会把我们带向何方。这就是为什么我关于如何训练大脑做困难事情的第一个最大建议是“五分钟规则”。你知道，在你开始之后，任何事情的前五分钟都是最困难的，因为你必须是那个最困难的。必须深入挖掘并找到动力去开始，去处理从无到有带来的那种紧张感。而这之所以如此令人生畏，很大一部分原因是它感觉像
when we begin a new task or we begin a new routine or we're like, okay, I'm committed to going to the gym every single morning or I'm committed to in this moment right now, finishing my assignment and I need to work on it in this moment right now, absolutely have to do it even though I don't want to do it. It often is like, okay, by telling myself that I need to do that, I now am committing to a lot more than just a couple of minutes. I'm committed to a whole process, a whole period of time where I have to be focused on this task. And it's that huge mountain and the idea of climbing that mountain knowing it's going to take a while that means that we put things off because of the time burden. Instead, we want to overcome our brain's natural tendency to want to avoid
当我们开始一项新任务或开始一个新的日常工作，或者我们像说，好吧，我承诺每天早上都去健身房，或者我承诺在这一刻，完成我的作业，我需要现在就做，即使我不想做。它通常就像是，好吧，通过告诉自己我需要做那个，我现在承诺的不仅仅是几分钟。我承诺的是整个过程，整个一段时间，我必须专注于这项任务。正是那座巨大的山，以及攀登那座山的想法，知道它需要一段时间，这意味着我们因为时间负担而推迟事情。相反，我们想要克服大脑天生想要避免的倾向
discomfort that comes with the beginning of the task by saying, I will just do this for five minutes. It's not actually a trick. You are only going to do the thing for five minutes unless after you have, you know, lasted that period of time, you feel better about the thing. You feel better about doing it. If you're five minutes into your run and you're like, okay, I've done five minutes. I can stop. I'm allowed to stop because I've done better than doing nothing. But, you know, maybe I'll just do another minute. Maybe I'll do another minute after that. You see that you have overcome the first mental barrier. You've overcome that first point of tension. This is just such a simple, accessible, cognitive behavioral strategy. And the reason that it works so much is also because
任务开始时带来的不适，通过说，我只会做五分钟。这实际上不是一个诡计。你真的只会做五分钟，除非在你（你知道）坚持了那段时间之后，你对这件事感觉更好。你对做这件事感觉更好。如果你跑步五分钟，然后你像说，好吧，我已经跑了五分钟。我可以停下来。我被允许停下来，因为我已经比什么都不做要好。但是，（你知道）也许我再跑一分钟。也许在那之后我再跑一分钟。你会看到你已经克服了第一个心理障碍。你已经克服了第一个紧张点。这只是一个非常简单、易于获取的认知行为策略。它之所以如此有效，也是因为
it essentially tricks us into not being able to procrastinate. Now, one of the foundations of procrastination, a lot of people think, assume that it's laziness. It's actually not, it's perfectionism. If you are an overachiever, you are a big thinker, you are a perfectionist. The beginning of a task is always going to be the hardest because it's in that moment that you really, you really, realize how much opportunity in space there is to fail, how much space there is to do it wrong, how much space there is to be criticized, to not live up to your expectations, that is scary. And that is what's causing you to procrastinate and causing you to put off this reality that you're so fearful of. But the five-minute rule undercuts that because it looks at this perfection
它本质上欺骗了我们，使我们无法拖延。现在，拖延症的基础之一，很多人认为，假设是懒惰。其实不是，是完美主义。如果你是一个追求卓越的人，你是一个大思想家，你是一个完美主义者。任务的开始总是最困难的，因为就在那一刻，你真的、你真的意识到有多少失败的机会和空间，有多少做错的空间，有多少被批评的空间，有多少无法达到你期望的空间，那很可怕。而这就是导致你拖延，导致你推迟这个你如此恐惧的现实的原因。但五分钟规则削弱了这一点，因为它看待这种完美
as part of our brain and says, actually, like, you can clock off for this because anything that I do in five minutes is not going to be perfect. So great, I know that. That's amazing. I can just actually ignore my perfectionism for this moment and just give it a go. It doesn't have to be perfect. It definitely doesn't have to be done. And by the time you have gotten that momentum, suddenly your perfectionism is kind of like trying to play catch up. It's like, hey, wait, you tricked me. I thought that we were like not actually going to do this today. I thought that we were going to like give it a break. Like I thought that, you know, I'd stopped you. It's like actually no. When you start giving it a go, when you get on like the fast train, you start seeing that it's easier. You start seeing that actually you're doing better than you expected,
作为我们大脑的一部分，并说，实际上，就像，你可以为此打卡下班，因为我在五分钟内做的任何事情都不会是完美的。所以太棒了，我知道这一点。那太棒了。我实际上可以在这一刻忽略我的完美主义，只是试一试。它不必是完美的。它绝对不必是完成的。当你获得那种动力时，突然间你的完美主义就像是在试图追赶。它就像是，嘿，等等，你骗了我。我以为我们今天实际上不会做这个。我以为我们要（你知道）休息一下。我以为，（你知道）我会阻止你。它就像实际上不。当你开始尝试，当你坐上快车，你开始看到它更容易。你开始看到实际上你做得比你预期的要好，
perhaps. And you also start realizing that progress is just, it's just important. You've already made a dent and now you have something to work with. So the five minute rule, anything that you know is going to be hard. Just say you have to do it for five minutes. And like I said before, you do only have to do it for five minutes. So if you're at the end of that period of time and you're like, okay, I want to stop, that's fine. You're allowed to stop, but at least you did it. My second tip, and this one is possibly one of my favorite strategies. I use this all the time. When I know I have to do something that is daunting, that is challenging, that I don't want to do, I picture the best person I know at that thing. I picture them doing it. I think about them. I think about how they hold themselves.
也许。而且你也开始意识到进步只是，它只是重要的。你已经取得了进展，现在你有了一些可以利用的东西。所以五分钟规则，任何你知道会很困难的事情。只要说你必须做五分钟。就像我之前说的，你确实只需要做五分钟。所以如果你在那段时间结束时，你像说，好吧，我想停下来，那没关系。你被允许停下来，但至少你做了。我的第二个建议，这个可能是我最喜欢的策略之一。我一直都在用。当我必须做一些令人生畏的、具有挑战性的、我不想做的事情时，我会想象我认识的在这方面最好的人。我想象他们在做这件事。我想着他们。我想着他们是如何保持自己的。
I think about how they would go about it. It's a really powerful form of mental imagery. And when we concoct these mental images in our brain, it serves as a form of motivation. So, for example, anytime I need to do public speaking, I always think about my mom because my mom is absolutely excellent at it. She's amazing. And I think about like almost stepping into her shoes, stepping into her outfit, believing that I am her. And it's that admiration, but also the fact that she has set an example that I can almost copy that makes me feel a lot more capable. It's almost like, I actually don't, you know, I don't have to do all of this myself. Someone else that I know, who I respect, who is great at this, has already done it for me. All I need to do,
我想着他们会如何去做。这是一种非常强大的心理意象形式。当我们在大脑中编造这些心理意象时，它就成为了一种动力来源。所以，例如，任何时候我需要进行公开演讲，我总是想到我的妈妈，因为我的妈妈在这方面绝对出色。她太棒了。我想着几乎是走进她的鞋子，穿上她的衣服，相信我就是她。正是那种钦佩，但也因为她树立了一个我可以几乎复制的榜样，这让我感觉自己更有能力。这几乎就像是，我实际上不需要，（你知道）我不需要自己做所有这些。我认识的另一个人，我尊重的，在这方面很棒的人，已经为我做过了。我所需要做的，
is emulate them. All I need to do is copy them. I also, I will say, do this at the gym all the time, like as a way to stick to the hard parts of like my gym workouts and my gym routine. But instead of thinking about the best person I know at the gym, which to be honest would probably also be my mom, which is crazy because she's just a legend. But instead of thinking about someone I really admire and copying them and thinking about what they would do, I actually also visualize this person in my mind called Jim Gemma or Elite Gemma. And Elite Gemma is like this really focused, fit version of myself that I've created. And I think about what she would do.
就是效仿他们。我所需要做的就是复制他们。我还要说，我在健身房一直这样做，作为坚持我健身锻炼和健身日常中困难部分的一种方式。但与其想到我认识的在健身房最好的人，说实话那可能也是我的妈妈，这很疯狂，因为她就是一个传奇。但与其想到我非常钦佩的人并复制他们，思考他们会做什么，我实际上也在脑海中想象这个叫“吉姆·杰玛”或“精英杰玛”的人。而“精英杰玛”就像是我创造的这个非常专注、健康的自己。我想着她会做什么。
I think about how confident she would be. I think about what move she would do, what her routine would look like, how she would go about it, would she care about those other people looking at her? No, she wouldn't. and elite Gemma is who I step into in those moments where I'm like, I don't really want to do this, but she would, and I have to listen to what she would do here, so I need to go. So there is a great study from 2019 on this exact topic, and it's titled Mental Imetry as a motivational amplifier to promote activities.
我想着她会多么自信。我想着她会做什么动作，她的日常会是什么样子，她会如何去做，她会在意那些看着她的人吗？不，她不会。而“精英杰玛”就是我在那些时刻所扮演的角色，当时我像说，我真的不想做这个，但她会做，我必须听听她在这里会做什么，所以我需要去。所以关于这个确切的主题，有一项来自2019年的伟大研究，标题是《作为促进活动动力放大器的心理意象》。
And I love this amplifier. It doesn't give you all the motivation to begin with, but it takes that tiny bit of sensation in you that wants to do something and says you are capable, you are able to do this. So this study, it showed that when participants visualized themselves doing hard activities or hard things and then being successful or finishing the task, this was associated with higher activity completion compared to those who were just given a task and told to go about it. The other reason and I guess the other way in which I think mental imagery is really important here is that it is a great source of bravery and it is a great way to fake it till you make it. And I'm going to give another example here of how I used a very similar visualization technique when I was trying to get over my fear of flying.
我喜欢这个放大器。它并不能从一开始就给你所有的动力，但它抓住了你内心想要做某事的那一点点感觉，并说你有能力，你有能力做这件事。所以这项研究表明，当参与者想象自己做困难的活动或困难的事情，然后取得成功或完成任务时，这与那些只是被分配任务并被告知去做的人相比，与更高的活动完成度相关联。我认为心理意象在这里非常重要的另一个原因，也是我认为它是勇敢的伟大来源，也是“假装直到你成功”的绝佳方式。我将在这里举另一个例子，说明当我试图克服飞行恐惧时，我是如何使用非常相似的视觉化技术的。
I would imagine that I was someone famous and I would really pick. being this like famous person who caught all these planes all the time this was like a part of my fast luxurious life and just like rehearsing that and thinking about that over and over again creating that mental loop and repetition I am this person I'm emulating this person it made me feel insanely powerful insanely capable and it was a complete game changer so that is a way that you can use your ability, your very amazing special human ability to create mental images in your mind, you can use that to trick yourself into feeling more capable. You've got to remember, your mind is the source of all your beliefs about how able you are and how brave you are
我会想象我是某个名人，我会真的选择。成为这个一直赶飞机的名人，这是我快节奏奢华生活的一部分，只是反复排练那个，反复思考那个，创造那个心理循环和重复，我是这个人，我在效仿这个人，这让我感觉无比强大，无比有能力，这是一个彻底的改变。所以这就是你可以利用你的能力，你非常神奇的特殊人类能力，在脑海中创造心理意象的方式，你可以利用它来欺骗自己，让自己感觉更有能力。你必须记住，你的大脑是你所有关于你有多能干、你有多勇敢的信念的来源
and how courageous you are. So if you feed it, all of this like artificial confidence that is based on how someone else does things or how a future or an amazing version of yourself does things, it's going to eat that up and it's not going to know the difference between that and a negative or self-doubting thought. So it's an incredible technique. Let's move on from this and talk about mood. Talk about emotions. So if you have got something on your to-do list that you have been avoiding for a while because it is hard, because it is boring, because you just simply don't want to do it, you have got to choose the right mood to start tackling that. You've got to choose the right mood to implement your five minutes.
以及你有多勇敢。所以如果你给它喂食所有这些基于别人如何做事，或者未来或一个了不起的你自己如何做事的虚假自信，它会吃掉它，它不会知道这与消极或自我怀疑的想法之间的区别。所以这是一个不可思议的技术。让我们从这里继续，谈谈情绪。谈谈情感。所以如果你的待办事项清单上有你一直在回避的事情，因为它很难，因为它很无聊，因为它只是你根本不想做，你必须选择正确的情绪来开始处理它。你必须选择正确的情绪来实施你的五分钟。
A 2016 study found that when people are upset, they are less likely to try and do hard things. Very common sense, I understand. Sometimes we do just need like a good old-fashioned psychological sense. study to prove what we already know. And the explanation behind why this is the case is also quite simple. When you're in a bad mood, all of your mental resources are at a lower point. They're all kind of plummeting, right? So you're not going to feel as motivated. You're not going to feel like you have any energy. You're also, well, your mind is going to look at this hard task and it's going to make it feel a lot bigger and a lot more difficult, a lot more challenging as a way
2016年的一项研究发现，当人们心烦意乱时，他们不太可能尝试做困难的事情。非常常识，我明白。有时我们确实需要像一个好的老式心理学研究来证明我们已经知道的事情。而这背后的解释也相当简单。当你心情不好时，你所有的心理资源都处于较低点。它们都在某种程度上暴跌，对吧？所以你不会感到那么有动力。你不会觉得你有任何精力。你也会，嗯，你的大脑会看着这个困难的任务，它会使它感觉大得多，困难得多，挑战性得多，作为一种
to convince you to rest, convince you to get yourself back to a positive mental state by not putting any more pressure on yourself as it is. During those times, that is not the time when you want to start doing the hard thing. That is not the time when you want to start doing your chores. That is not the time when you want to, you know, suddenly handle your taxes after you've had like a really long day at work. You've missed your train. You're having a fight with your friend. There's not enough food in the fridge. No. Because also another element of that is that you will end up resenting the activity even more when you have to do it when you're in a bad mood. And if you're trying to train yourself into a habit, but every time you go about doing the habit or practicing the
说服你休息的方式，通过不给自己施加任何额外的压力来说服你回到积极的心理状态。在那些时候，那不是你想开始做困难事情的时候。那不是你想开始做家务的时候。那不是你想（你知道）在工作了一整天后突然处理税务的时候。你错过了火车。你正在和朋友吵架。冰箱里没有足够的食物。不。因为那其中的另一个因素是，当你心情不好时不得不做这件事，你最终会更加怨恨这项活动。如果你试图训练自己养成一个习惯，但每次你去做这个习惯或练习
behavior that is associated with it. Every time you do that, if you're in a terrible mood, guess what's going to become associated? The terrible mood and the behavior. And it's going to become almost like this pattern or this link or this relationship in your brain that when you think about the task, when you think about the whatever it is thing that you need to do, your brain's going to be like, huh, every time we do that, we're in a bad mood. And it doesn't see like the correlation or the causation point. sorry, it doesn't see like the chicken or the egg problem, which one came first. So it's really important
与它相关的行为。每次你这样做，如果你心情很糟糕，猜猜会发生什么关联？糟糕的心情和行为。它会变得几乎像大脑中的这种模式或这种联系或这种关系，当你想到任务时，当你想到你需要做的任何事情时，你的大脑会像说，哈，每次我们做那个，我们心情都很糟糕。它看不到像相关性或因果关系点。抱歉，它看不到像鸡生蛋还是蛋生鸡的问题，哪个先发生。所以这真的很重要
to build positive associations when we are doing hard things. I'm going to use the gym example again and just think that it's like the easiest because it's like a behavior where you go to the same place and it's like something that a lot of us are probably going to be focused on in the new years. If you are in a really bad mood, and I'm going to tell you something that is probably counterintuitive, if you are in a really bad mood and one of your long-time goals is to, go to the gym more often, actually don't go to the gym during those times. Some people would argue that the endorphins are going to make you feel better, yada, yada, yada, in some ways I think that is the case. But if you're going to go to the gym and just do a really crappy workout and you're not going to
当我们做困难的事情时，建立积极的联系。我将再次使用健身房的例子，只是认为它是最简单的，因为它就像一种行为，你去同一个地方，它就像我们很多人可能在新年里会关注的事情。如果你心情真的很糟糕，我要告诉你一件可能违反直觉的事情，如果你心情真的很糟糕，而你的长期目标之一是更频繁地去健身房，实际上在那些时候不要去健身房。有些人会争辩说内啡肽会让你感觉更好，等等等等，在某些方面我认为确实如此。但如果你要去健身房，只是做一次非常糟糕的锻炼，你甚至不会
feel like you push yourself, you're not even going to get to that place of an endorphine high, actually what you're doing before you even get there is associating the bad mood with the behavior. So when you are in the best mood, you've had a great day, you're feeling motivated, that's when you've got to almost like slide in the hard tasks. It's like when parents like sneak vegetables into like meatballs or into like cookies, that's what you're doing here. Someone said to me when I like first talked to them about this, like that's such a waste of a good mood. Like why would I do that? But actually completing a hard task when you are already in a good mood has been shown to elevate that mood even further.
感觉你推动了自己，你甚至不会达到那种内啡肽高潮，实际上你在到达那里之前所做的是将糟糕的心情与行为联系起来。所以当你心情最好时，你度过了美好的一天，你感到有动力，那就是你几乎必须（像）滑入困难任务的时候。这就像父母把蔬菜偷偷放进肉丸或饼干里一样，这就是你在这里所做的。当我第一次和他们谈论这个时，有人对我说，那真是浪费了好心情。我为什么要那样做？但实际上，当你心情已经很好时完成一项困难的任务，已被证明会进一步提升那种心情。
And there is a continuation. So you feel really good in the moment, but then you also continue to feel good in the minutes, hours, even sometimes days afterwards. Maybe in part because of relief, like, oh gosh, finally, I did it, that's done. But also in part because of a sense of pride. You know, how often do we actually challenge ourselves? And seriously, when was the last time?
而且有一个延续。所以你在那一刻感觉很好，但随后你在接下来的几分钟、几小时，甚至有时几天里也会继续感觉良好。也许部分是因为解脱，就像，哦天哪，终于，我做到了，那完成了。但也部分是因为一种自豪感。你知道，我们多久真正挑战自己一次？说真的，上一次是什么时候？
time you put a lot of effort into something and it took a lot of commitment from you. And there were times when you doubted yourself and you didn't really want to do it. When was the last time you did that? Because as an adult, I do think that that's not as common anymore. It might be in like a workplace environment. But when it comes to your personal life, we very often, we don't tend to often, you're just jumping all over my words there, we don't often tend to changing it up again. We don't often tend to actually push ourselves. So I think that it's really important to actually give yourself the opportunity to do that, to give yourself the confidence booster, to give yourself that further amplifier to your mood.
你投入了大量努力在某件事上，它需要你大量的承诺。而且有几次你怀疑自己，你真的不想做。上一次你那样做是什么时候？因为作为一个成年人，我确实认为那不再那么常见了。它可能在像工作场所的环境中。但当谈到你的个人生活时，我们非常经常，我们不倾向于经常，你只是在我的话上跳来跳去，我们不经常倾向于再次改变它。我们不经常倾向于真正推动自己。所以我认为真正给自己机会去做这件事，给自己自信心助推器，给自己那种对心情的进一步放大器，真的很重要。
Alrighty. We're going to take a short little break because obviously I need to have a drink of water since I am just tumbling all over my words here. but when we return, we're going to talk about how you can fall in love with the process and the different kinds of extrinsic, intrinsic, and integrated motivation that you can use to do hard things. Stay with us. We'll be right back. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
好了。我们要休息一小会儿，因为显然我需要喝口水，因为我只是在我的话语中跌跌撞撞。但当我们回来时，我们将谈论你如何爱上这个过程，以及你可以用来做困难事情的各种外在、内在和整合动机。和我们在一起。我们马上回来。《2%》。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了关于心理韧性、
fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will calm out, on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
健身和建立复原力的科学，在这个奇怪的现代世界中。我将与作家、研究人员和其他健康与健身专家以及更多人交谈，以看透统治健康产业的不切实际和过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上是促炎的。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些磨难，你最终会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at a podcast. I'm Sam Jek.
请收听《2%》。在I-Hart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。
And I'm Alex In. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
我是亚历克斯·英。每一集，我们都会挑选一年，拆解当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时光的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代的快克。明确地说，84年对我来说很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我整天都愿意谈论快克，但只是让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集。所以我开始看到有一条贯穿线。我们现在桌上还有艾滋病。
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
谢谢你完成那个句子。我不认为有比这更重要的黑人年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师，基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
我在谈论。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们太沉迷于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候已经做得足够了。因为人们在看记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你发现做一个好人很重要，当你活在地球上时。
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose
你是一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两种不同程度的信任。我希望你真的做一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，我们将进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话
on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》上。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃卡德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了她故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这开启了一场长达数年的法庭斗争来证明真相。你篡改了这个特定的测试两次，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的税款被用于什么。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们揭开了一个令人不安的模式。还有两个男人也经历过同样的事情。
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
格雷，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们，先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控欺诈。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never. mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their
请在IHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，永远不要招惹乡村女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，你就会得到愚蠢的奖品。规则二，也永远不要招惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德，在《The Girlfriends》的新一季中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上？警察似乎并不关心。所以她们决定采取行动。
own hands. I said, oh, hell no, I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There is a psychological theory that when we don't just fall in love with the result, but we fall in love with the process, we actually perform better and we get further. and this theory is known as learned industriousness. Here is the thing about doing everything for like the big golden finish line, right? Anything hard you are just thinking about what it's going to be like when it's done, when it's over, when you have the reward.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的。请收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听。有一个心理学理论认为，当我们不仅仅爱上结果，而是爱上过程时，我们实际上表现得更好，走得更远。这个理论被称为“习得性勤奋”。关于为了像大金终点线那样做所有事情，这里有一件事，对吧？任何困难的事情，你只是在想当它完成时、当它结束时、当你得到回报时会是什么样子。
It actually takes a while to get there. And along that path, along that route, there's probably not going to be a lot of, you know, encouragement to spur you want. People might not believe in you. the thing that you're doing might just be very mundane, no one's going to be celebrating you, shouting like, yay, you've got this. Maybe there's not like any reward that you could even provide yourself during that time. So if you are doing it all for the final outcome, you are going to unfortunately probably lose steam. So what this theory says is that individuals who are reinforced
到达那里确实需要一段时间。沿着那条道路，沿着那条路线，可能不会有很多（你知道）鼓励来激励你。人们可能不相信你。你正在做的事情可能只是非常平凡，没有人会为你庆祝，大喊像，耶，你做到了。也许在那段时间里，甚至没有任何你可以提供给自己的奖励。所以如果你做这一切都是为了最终的结果，你很可能会不幸地失去动力。所以这个理论说的是，那些因为在任务上付出高努力而得到强化的人，
for exerting high effort on a task, they don't just fall in love with the outcome. They actually in some ways get hooked or get addicted purely to the sensation of performing highly, purely to the sensation of exerting themselves. So we flip the whole narrative away from the physical, tangible outcome and towards a love for like the everyday hard actions that get us there. So how do we do that? Well, a few ways. Firstly, is by really romanticising the process, really falling in love and getting quite sentimental about what it feels like to perform a task day and day out, what it feels like to be working towards your goals. Like what a privilege that is, how romantic it is.
他们不仅仅爱上结果。他们实际上在某种程度上迷上了或沉迷于纯粹的高表现感觉，纯粹沉迷于付出努力的感觉。所以我们将整个叙事从身体上的、有形的成果转向对那些让我们到达那里的日常困难行动的热爱。那么我们该怎么做呢？嗯，几种方式。首先，是通过真正浪漫化这个过程，真正爱上并对日复一日执行任务的感觉变得相当感性，对为目标而努力的感觉是什么样子的。就像那是一种多么大的特权，它是多么浪漫。
What's that story going to look like? What's that going to feel like? I did this a lot when I was writing my book and I was staying up late and I felt very stressed. But instead of being like, oh my God, this just sucks it. I'm just so tired. I would like imagine that I was Ernest Hemingway or like a famous author working into the night in Paris on my book with a glass of wine and I was like this tortured author poet type and I created this whole image that made me really feel like it was like
那个故事会是什么样子？那会是什么感觉？当我写书时，我经常这样做，我熬夜，我感到压力很大。但与其像，哦天哪，这太糟糕了。我太累了。我会想象我是欧内斯特·海明威或某个著名的作家，在巴黎的深夜里写着我的书，喝着一杯酒，我就像这种受折磨的作家诗人类型，我创造了整个形象，让我真的觉得它就像
fun it was fun to not so much suffer but it was fun to strive it was fun to work hard there was like this glamour associated with it there was this romanticism that made it special and fun and I have actually like very fond memories of those times. You know, even when it was really, really late, it felt nice knowing that I could push myself. Another way of doing this is by really noticing the signs of progress and letting them serve as the reward to kind of further fuel your fire. So the feeling of sore muscles, the feeling of being really mentally tired at the end of the day, but like super fulfilled and super satisfied and like falling.
很有趣，不那么痛苦，但奋斗很有趣，努力工作很有趣，有一种与它相关的魅力，有一种浪漫主义使它变得特别和有趣，我实际上对那些时光有非常美好的回忆。你知道，即使在非常、非常晚的时候，知道我能推动自己，感觉也很好。另一种方法是真正注意到进步的迹象，并让它们作为奖励来进一步点燃你的火焰。所以肌肉酸痛的感觉，在一天结束时感到非常精神疲惫，但像超级充实和超级满足，并像坠入。
falling asleep and just feeling really great about yourself. The feeling of seeing, I don't know, your art get better, seeing your writing get better, seeing your grades get better. That is a way of bringing about learned industriousness. It's why I really, one of the things I really recommend and that I love when people do this is when they set up Instagram pages for like their projects, like their marathons or an art project or like when they're learning your language or. or when they're renovating their house, like setting up a progress page or a project page,
入睡时对自己感觉非常好。看到自己的艺术水平提高、写作水平提高、成绩提高的那种感觉。这就是带来习得性勤奋的一种方式。这就是为什么我非常推荐，而且我很喜欢人们这样做，那就是为他们的项目建立Instagram页面，比如马拉松、艺术项目、学习语言，或者装修房子时，建立一个进度页面或项目页面，
you can really see how things get better and improve and get bigger and larger and dreams come true. My God, I sound so cliche. But you really can see that day in and day out. It gets better every single day. Finally, the best way to really promote learned industriousness and the way that really aligns best with the theory is to just simply reinforce your effort through physical reward. So what this really relies on is something known as the hedonic principle. As humans, as creatures, as people with brains, we are wired
你可以真正看到事情是如何变得更好、如何进步、如何变得更大，梦想是如何成真的。天哪，我听起来太陈词滥调了。但你确实可以日复一日地看到这一点。每一天都在变得更好。最后，促进习得性勤奋的最佳方式，也是最符合该理论的方式，就是通过物质奖励来简单地强化你的努力。所以这实际上依赖于所谓的享乐原则。作为人类，作为生物，作为有大脑的人，我们天生
towards things that make us feel good and we are wired to avoid things that make us feel uncomfortable. Super simple principle, right? But an easy way to make an uncomfortable thing feel good is by maximum maximizing the pleasure and the reward we get from it. So the more candy, I don't know, like the more candy you offer to a child, the more excited they're going to be to go to the dentist, even if they hate the dentist. The more treats you give a puppy, like the more obedient they become, allegedly, that's always backfired and made my puppies and dogs super fat. But you know what I mean? You can also do this for yourself by providing like physical rewards, artificial rewards, that you give yourself in lieu of the bigger reward.
倾向于让我们感觉良好的事物，而天生会避免让我们感到不舒服的事物。非常简单的原则，对吧？但让不舒服的事情感觉良好的一种简单方法，就是最大化我们从中获得的快乐和奖励。所以，给孩子提供的糖果越多，他们去牙医那里的兴奋感就越强，即使他们讨厌牙医。给小狗的零食越多，它们就变得越听话，据说是这样，但这总是适得其反，让我的小狗和狗变得超级胖。但你知道我的意思吗？你也可以通过提供物质奖励、人为奖励来为自己做到这一点，作为更大奖励的替代品。
One way we see people do this is by creating a schedule for positive reinforcement. That's an incredible behavioral change strategy. So people do this for savings goals a lot. I see this a lot on like TikTok and Instagram and I love seeing these. Every like $100, $200, $200, $1,000 they save, $20, $50, whatever it is, goes into buying something that they really, really want so that there is that reinforcement that's going along with the hard work. We all kind of do want a special little thing every now and again.
我们看到人们这样做的一种方式是制定正强化时间表。这是一种不可思议的行为改变策略。人们经常为储蓄目标这样做。我在TikTok和Instagram上经常看到这种情况，我很喜欢看到这些。每存够100美元、200美元、1000美元，无论多少，都会用来买他们非常非常想要的东西，这样就有了伴随努力工作的强化。我们每个人偶尔都想要一点特别的小东西。
We want a break every now and again. We want a sweet treat every now and again. Factor that into how you are going about your goals, whatever it is, especially if it's a goal that is really based on a deficit of something. So having less saving money, having less sweet treats, having less downtime because you're working really, really hard. You can use that as a form of motivation to make you want to work harder so that you finally get the reward. We see like studies on this with rats all the time, you know, the more that they are reinforced in a structured way. So, you know, they finish a task, they get a treat. They
我们偶尔想要休息一下。我们偶尔想要一点甜食。把你如何实现目标的过程考虑进去，无论目标是什么，特别是如果这是一个基于某种匮乏的目标。比如少存钱、少吃甜食、少休息，因为你工作非常非常努力。你可以利用这一点作为一种动力，让你想要更努力地工作，这样你最终就能得到奖励。我们经常看到关于老鼠的研究，你知道，它们在结构化的方式下得到更多的强化。所以，你知道，它们完成了一个任务，就得到一个奖励。它们
finish the next task that's a little bit harder. They get a treat. The more that there is that structured reward, they end up performing better. They're more efficient. They tire. less easily. And let's just say this, that it's not like a factor to do with energy. Like the reward is sometimes like they get to see their friend or the reward is like a pat. Like it's not always food based, but they actually keep going for longer. The reason this is is the case in scientifically, neurologically, the reason this is the case all comes down to dopamine. I think we all know like dopamine is the happy chemical. Dopamine is also the motivational chemical. It is the chemical that gets you to do things. So if you want to increase the dopamine that you are accessing when doing
完成了下一个稍微难一点的任务。它们就得到一个奖励。结构化奖励越多，它们的表现就越好。它们效率更高。更不容易疲劳。而且我们得说，这与能量因素无关。比如奖励有时是它们能见到朋友，或者奖励是拍拍它们。这并不总是基于食物，但它们实际上能坚持更长时间。从科学和神经学角度来看，这种情况的原因归结为多巴胺。我想我们都知道多巴胺是快乐化学物质。多巴胺也是动力化学物质。它是让你去做事情的化学物质。所以如果你想增加你在做
hard things, you've got to provide some form of catalyst for the release of that, some form of trigger, some form of reward. It will make you happier, but it will also make you more motivated. There you go. The more you know. So when we do this, it's actually what creates intrinsic motivation. This is the first form of motivation we're going to be talking about. Intrinsic motivation is when you do think just because you love them and just because you find them enjoyable. So you don't have to force yourself to do things you love, right? Like, I wouldn't have to force you to go to the beach. I wouldn't have to force you to like have a wine with your friends or force you to
困难事情时所获取的多巴胺，你必须提供某种催化剂来释放它，某种触发器，某种奖励。这会让你更快乐，但也会让你更有动力。就是这样。你知道得越多越好。所以当我们这样做时，这实际上创造了内在动机。这是我们将要讨论的第一种动机。内在动机是指你做某事仅仅是因为你热爱它，仅仅是因为你觉得它很有趣。所以你不必强迫自己去做你热爱的事情，对吧？比如，我不必强迫你去海滩。我不必强迫你和朋友喝红酒，或者强迫你
read your favorite book because you just like doing it. And one way that we can make it so that we enjoy doing something, which is the highest form of motivation for actually doing it, is by associating positive experiences and rewards. with performance, determination, commitment, with, you know, doing the thing with being persistent. Now, I know what you're probably thinking. How do I fall in love with doing something that is just actually so frustrating and annoying and something that I really don't want to do?
读你最喜欢的书，因为你就是喜欢做这些事。我们可以让享受做某事成为可能，这是实际去做某事的最高动力，方法是将积极的体验和奖励与表现、决心、承诺，以及坚持不懈地做某事联系起来。现在，我知道你可能在想什么。我该如何爱上做一件实际上非常令人沮丧、烦人，而且我真的不想做的事情呢？
And like, how do I enjoy my job that involves firing people? How do I fall in love with the process there? or how do I fall in love with my painful IVF treatment? You know, that just sucks. Or like, how do I become intrinsically motivated to enjoy cleaning my toilet? There's just some things where this isn't possible, like we can't use this hedonic or pleasure principle. So the next best thing that you can aim for is integrated motivation.
比如，我该如何享受我那份涉及解雇他人的工作？我该如何爱上那个过程？或者我该如何爱上我那痛苦的试管婴儿治疗？你知道，那真的很糟糕。或者，我该如何产生内在动力去享受打扫厕所？有些事情是不可能的，我们不能使用这种享乐或快乐原则。所以你可以追求的次优选择是整合动机。
So this occurs when a behavior is performed to gain both an experience. external reward, but it also aligns, aligns with your sense of identity, your sense of, the internal sense of value and interests and who you are as a person. We can make our motivation to complete a task attached to our identity, and it's super, super powerful. You know, I clean the toilet because I'm someone who is conscientious and I'm someone who cares about cleanliness and I care about having a nice environment. And because I am someone who cares about the details, even though I don't enjoy this, I'm going to do it because it reinforces something that I find important about my identity. I go through IVF treatment, even when it's painful, even when it's hard, because I want
这发生在行为被执行以获得外部奖励，同时也与你的身份认同、你的价值观、兴趣以及你作为一个人的本质相一致时。我们可以将完成任务的动力与我们的身份联系起来，这非常非常强大。你知道，我打扫厕所是因为我是一个有责任心的人，我是一个关心清洁的人，我关心拥有一个良好的环境。因为我是一个关心细节的人，尽管我不喜欢这样做，但我还是会做，因为它强化了我认为对我的身份很重要的东西。我经历试管婴儿治疗，即使它很痛苦，即使它很艰难，因为我想
to be a parent. That is something I have always felt is a deep part of my life purpose. So I will endure the hard part of this journey because the outcome is something that is significant for my identity. The second best way that you can do hard things is to get super clear on the why and make a really, really big picture, like give it a meaning as big as life itself. Like I study because I believe in creating a better life for myself and I am someone who is a hard worker. So this behavior, although it is hard, is something that reinforces what I believe about myself. It reinforces my self-concept. it reinforces my confidence, this is who I am. So who would I be if I didn't do this behavior? Who would I be if I didn't do these hard things? This is just so, so powerful for taking something
成为一名父母。这是我一直觉得是我人生目标中深刻的一部分。所以我将忍受这段旅程的艰难部分，因为结果对我个人的身份意义重大。做困难事情的第二好方法是弄清楚为什么，并勾勒出一个非常非常宏大的图景，赋予它像生命本身一样重大的意义。比如我学习是因为我相信为自己创造更好的生活，而且我是一个努力工作的人。所以这种行为，尽管很困难，但它强化了我对自己的信念。它强化了我的自我概念，它强化了我的自信，这就是我。那么如果我不做这种行为，我会是谁呢？如果我不做这些困难的事情，我会是谁呢？这对于把某件事
that is just, you know, a random thing on your to-do list, or maybe not, taking something that you have, you know, mixed feelings towards, it's uncomfortable, it's difficult, and it becomes this thing, this gateway to being a more true, authentic. version of yourself. And of course you are going to want to do that hard thing over the hard thing that is just bothersome, over the hard thing that you have no meaning attached to. Finally, you know, if that doesn't work, if the intrinsic motivation doesn't work and the like integrated motivation systems don't work, you can always rely on extrinsic motivation. And that is basically doing things publicly, doing things in a public sense.
仅仅是待办事项清单上的一件随机事情，或者也许不是，把你有复杂感受的事情，它是不舒服的、困难的，变成通往成为一个更真实、更纯粹的自己的途径。当然，你会想要做那件困难的事情，而不是那些令人烦恼的、没有意义的困难事情。最后，你知道，如果那不起作用，如果内在动机不起作用，整合动机系统也不起作用，你总是可以依赖外在动机。这基本上就是公开地做事情，在公共场合做事情。
in front of others, promising others that you're going to do it as a way to make you feel like you're accountable, make you feel like there are eyes on you. This is all rooted in social psychology when we think that people are watching. We tend to behave better. We tend to put on our best behavior. You can use those same principles to force yourself to do hard things. One of my friends does this in an excellent way. She studies in very public places. because it, you know, makes her feel almost embarrassed to go on her phone, like the acknowledgement that someone could be watching her. And someone might be like, oh, God, she's going on her phone. Like, that's not good. I thought she was studying. Yes, sometimes it might not be the best for
在他人面前，向他人承诺你会做这件事，以此让你感到自己有责任感，让你感到有人在注视着你。这都植根于社会心理学，当我们认为有人在看时。我们倾向于表现得更好。我们倾向于展现出最好的行为。你可以利用同样的原则来强迫自己做困难的事情。我的一个朋友以一种极好的方式做到了这一点。她在非常公共的地方学习，因为这让她感到如果玩手机会很尴尬，比如意识到有人可能在看着她。有人可能会说，天哪，她在玩手机。那不好。我以为她在学习。是的，有时这可能不是最适合
certain goals or certain behaviours. But in terms of things where you're like, I just need to get this done. And I need someone who, you know, a stranger, doesn't even know me. I just need their presence to make me feel obligated to do this. incredibly powerful. That was my final tip for the day. We talked about intrinsic, integrated, an external or extrinsic motivation. Intrinsic is the best, actually finding a way to enjoy or fall in love with the process. Secondly, you can find a way to make the activity a part or a reinforcer of an important part of your identity. And then if all that fails, you know, the floodgates roll open, you can rely on the judgment of others.
某些目标或某些行为。但就那些你觉得我只需要完成这件事，而且我需要一个陌生人，甚至不认识我的人，我只需要他们的存在让我感到有义务去做这件事的情况而言，这非常强大。这是我今天的最后一个建议。我们谈到了内在动机、整合动机和外部或外在动机。内在动机是最好的，实际上是找到一种享受或爱上这个过程的方法。其次，你可以找到一种方法，使这项活动成为你身份重要组成部分的一部分或强化因素。然后如果所有这些都失败了，你知道，闸门打开了，你可以依赖他人的评判。
Less than ideal, but sometimes important. I really hope that this episode has given you some motivation. You know, we've got one month left of this year. We've got so much going on. We have a lot of goals that we might want to achieve. And we also might be like preparing for next year. So I think these strategies are really, really doable and they're not about discipline. They're not about like working yourself to the bone. They're not about burnout and exhaustion. They are small things that you can do, mentally, psychologically, to be more productive and less busy and to reach your goals faster by essentially like tricking how our brain works and tricking our psychology. So if you did enjoy this episode, please make sure that you have left a five-star review.
虽然不太理想，但有时很重要。我真的希望这一集能给你一些动力。你知道，今年还剩下一个月。我们有很多事情要做。我们有很多可能想要实现的目标。而且我们可能也在为明年做准备。所以我认为这些策略非常非常可行，它们不是关于纪律。它们不是关于把自己累垮。它们不是关于倦怠和精疲力竭。它们是你可以在心理上、精神上做的小事，通过本质上欺骗我们大脑的工作方式和心理，来提高效率、减少忙碌并更快地实现目标。所以如果你喜欢这一集，请确保你留下了五星好评。
If you leave a review on Apple as well, I am looking at all of them at the moment. I'm like grabbing some out for a little post at the end of the year. I would really appreciate if you could leave some kind words there. also make sure you have pre-ordered the book. I know I've been kind of not on the ball with reminding you guys, but yeah, it comes out next year and there will be a link in the podcast episode description, even if you just want to check out the cover. That's totally fine.
如果你也在Apple上留下了评论，我目前正在查看所有评论。我正在挑选一些作为年底的小贴文。如果你能在那里留下一些暖心的话，我将不胜感激。还要确保你预订了这本书。我知道我提醒你们这件事有点不及时，但它明年就会出版，播客剧集描述中会有一个链接，即使你只是想看看封面也没关系。
I just appreciate any support that you are giving me this like crazy, amazing time in my life. Make sure you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. And until next time, stay safe, stay kind, be gentle to yourself. and we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我只是感谢你在我生命中这个疯狂而美妙的时刻给予我的任何支持。确保你在Instagram上关注我们，账号是That Psychology Podcast。直到下次，保持安全，保持友善，善待自己。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯的情况下选择走楼梯的人数比例。
I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我是Michael Easter。我在我的播客《2%》中。我剖析了心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English.
在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说也很重要。我是Sam Jay。我是Alex English。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那一年的。与我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行和最喜欢的作家一起。比如Mark Lamont Hill谈论80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我不认为对黑人来说有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
你正在收听《Learn the Hardway》，主持人是你最喜欢的治疗师Keer Games。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，在其他任何地方进行这些对话都不安全，但你是在与一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，单身汉明星Clayton Eckerd被指控生下双胞胎。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
但怀孕似乎是一个骗局。Owens女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。Greg，一个女同性恋。Michael Mancini。我的大脑被震撼了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with him.
我是Stephanie Young。这是《Love Trapped》。Laura，Scottsdale警察局。随着季节的继续，Laura Owens终于面临后果。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们采取了行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚。
this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他会得到他应得的。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友。在IHeart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是人类制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。